why are there seven million people and
why do each one of us have our own
fingerprint even twins have different
fingerprints who are otherwise
genetically identical why would you
rather we were all the same no I'm not
why is that more odd to you than the
fact that we all have different
personalities we have different talents
but personalities can be based on what
you learn environment
not sure and not just nature right so I
thought about the other day and it like
kind of made me spin it's just like we
all have different fingerprints okay I
get it
grand design well so it's an intriguing
fact but here's something that may
relate most people who could be born
will never be born will never even exist
so the fact that sperm okay yeah sure
yeah yeah one gets 98 science the rest
don't
so where do they go yeah they're part of
the number of human beings that will
never ever be born so the fuel because
there's not enough Souls
that would be something if you ran out
of Souls what would a soulless person
look like do you believe you have a soul
I don't know what a soul is I know
there's what here's something that
freaks me out every day every morning I
wake up and I say how is it that every
morning I wake up as me and not as
someone else oh yeah yeah it's this is
weird being me what is it like being you
right what's something it's like why am
i me every day Wow how does that happen
we have these electro chemicals in our
head and somehow that's me and on me
every day as far as I know as far as now
I wonder if I woke up as a different
person each day would I know it
[Music]